good evening my name is alan bernstein
and i'm the president and CEO of CFR
imagine that later this evening some
aliens are going to visit us here at the
Artscape Daniel's launch pad from
another planet imagine that the
immediately the man to know what is our
most proud achievements
what does almost our proudest
accomplishments what would we say well
of course being at an Arts Center we
could cite the words of Bach Sowinski
the group of seven Shakespeare Picasso
yet what these beautiful works be
understood or even appreciated by other
sentient beings with experiences and
worlds unimaginably different from our
own after all even when Picasso started
doing his cubist paintings other humans
failed to appreciate his art and when
Stravinsky's Rite of Spring was first
performed the audience fled from the
hall why then would we expect aliens to
appreciate our own artistic
accomplishments but there is one area of
human accomplishment of which we can
rightly boast it is the one achievement
that reflects the unique power of the
human brain and our curiosity about the
world around us and it is why our
species is called homo sapiens which
means wise humans and that achievements
that uniquely human achievement is
called science science has explained
much about the history and the mystery
of the universe the physical laws that
govern all matter
the mechanisms of heredity and soon an
understanding of how we think and feel
and the fruits of sound of science have
transformed our world in Myriad's of
ways consider smallpox smallpox killed
approximately 300 million people in the
20th century in this century no one will
die of smallpox no one that's science
the fruits of science have also doubled
our lifespan as Canadians since
Confederation doubled our lifespan since
Confederation science has made it
possible to light and heat our homes
science has saved over
one billion lives due to vaccines and
antibiotics in the 20th century science
has provided evidence driven changes in
social policy scientific research has
been a catalyst for equity-based social
movements including a woman's right to
vote
education for all and healthcare for all
in many countries we truly live in an
age defined by and transformed by
science that's why I have the best job
in Canada in fact I think I have the
best job in the world
a CFR's president and as a scientist I
oversee a global network of the world's
very top scientists their collaborators
our partners and our donors who together
are transforming our understanding of
the biological the physical and the
social worlds in which we live and in
the process are transforming our world
that's what I call impact CFR convenes
the world's top scientists to address
complex questions such as how does our
childhood experiences and our
socio-economic status affect our
trajectory of lifelong health
how do microbes that live in and on us
our microbiome affect our health a human
evolution and how we power our behavior
what can nature teach us about
harvesting and storing energy from the
Sun how can we understand the molecular
underpinnings of human intelligence what
is consciousness why are some societies
successful and others not these are all
examples of sea fire programs that are
going on at the very moment but science
is much much more than that
put simply it is the best way that
humanity has come up with to understand
and approve the world in which we live
science creates revolutions and
revelations that echo right across
generations but scientific discoveries
have not only advanced our understanding
of the world they have lifted the veil
of ignorance superstition and terror
that has characterized much of
humanity's experiences before science
today science is addressing the great
challenges our world is facing those
challenges
but a few terrorism food and water
security mental health infectious
disease think of Kovac 19 and of course
the climate crisis to name but a few are
global and they all require scientific
research for their solution and that's
where CFR comes in as a canadian-based
global organization we convene the
world's top scientists 400 at the moment
from 23 countries who work together
across disciplines to address the
solutions needed to address the most
important questions facing science and
humanity CFR was founded on a
disarmingly simple idea the best way to
address the important questions of our
time is to bring together the best
people across disciplines and borders to
engage in deep thinking and discussions
about their solutions we identify big
complex and challenging questions and
then identify the very best scientists
from anywhere in the world to work on
those questions we create a safe space
where brilliant minds come together to
form global communities challenge each
other as colleagues forge new
collaborations across disciplines and
hopefully changed the world's thinking
about an important question
that's simple idea led to the current
breakthrough in artificial intelligence
our understanding of the importance of
early years of the early years and
insights into the central role that
strong institutions play and economic
growth consider artificial intelligence
for a moment - AI about 20 years ago CFR
brought together a very small group of
mathematicians computer scientists
neurophysiologists and cognitive
psychologists with the goal to
understand how humans learn over the
decades that followed that seif our team
developed new insights that resulted in
deep learning and the revolution and AI
taking place around the world yes
AI is a Canadian breakthrough and we are
all reaping the benefits of that made in
Canada discovery through the high-tech
explosion taking place here in Toronto
Montreal inhabited and across the
country and the sea far as really global
Scholars Program supported by the as
reality foundation and Nancy and John
love identifies the
most promising young scientists and
provides the funds and mentorship they
need to launch their successful careers
because of science we live longer we
suffer less and we enjoy lives that were
unimaginable even a hundred years ago we
have learned to advance and apply
knowledge robust knowledge not acquired
by superstition or myth but by science
and evidence to improve the human
condition and that's why investments in
science always has impact science is
indeed the light that illuminates the
darkness in the world by advancing our
understanding of the world and science
reflects the very best of our humanity
the use of our brain and our curiosity
to understand that the world around us
it is this curiosity this insistence on
the challenging of dogma and belief I
think that would impress those
extraterrestrial visitors that we're all
going to meet later on this evening
I encourage you to think about how
science has made an impact on your own
life from the last time you used your
cell phone to flipping a switch to turn
on a light to the flu vaccine that I
hope you all got to a loved one who is
alive because of scientific research the
donors who support CFR are truly
impressive because they understand that
despite the long timelines involved the
impact of of science on our lives is
staggering science has truly changed our
world
they understand that if you want impact
if you want to change the world you can
do no better than to invest in science
and it see far thank you for your
attention
[Applause]